am i nostradamus am i nostradamus
over the past couple of weeks everyone
has been focusing on the many evils of
the taliban the taliban you see are the
bad guys they're our enemies they're the
enemies of our pure and innocent allies
we have been told and you will recall
that i urged caution i pointed out on
this show and in a column you know i
hate to say i told you so that that
allies quote unquote in afghanistan
change by the day
actually there are no allies in
afghanistan there are only interests
the guys who started the taliban were
our allies in the 1980s
they were the allies of our allies in
the 1990s even though those allies that
they were the allies have turned out
probably to be our enemies now they were
our enemies over the past two decades
but now there are allies again in the
fight against isis one week ago these
were the worst people on earth today
joe biden's national security adviser is
talking about sending them foreign aid
you say we're going to work with the
taliban does that include the prospect
of giving them aid
well first of all we do believe that
there is an important dimension of
humanitarian assistance that should go
directly to the people of afghanistan
they need help with respect to health
and food aid and other forms of
subsistence and we do intend to continue
that secondly when it comes to our
economic and development assistance
relationship with the taliban that will
be about the taliban's actions it will
be about whether they follow through on
their commitments their commitments to
safe passage for americans and afghan
allies their commitment to not allow
afghanistan to be
a base from which terrorists can attack
the united states or any other country
their commitments with respect to
upholding their international
obligations it's going to be up to them
and and we will wait and see by their
actions how we end up responding uh in
terms of the economic and development
assistance in other words once you get
past all that mealy math nonsense yes we
are going to fund the taliban we
probably are already doing it and we've
certainly already armed the taliban and
joe biden will call that a victory and
the media will cheer him on and everyone
will forget about the stranded americans
everyone that is except for the gop
congressman who is currently missing in
afghanistan according to reports because
he's on a rogue mission to rescue a
family of five but other than that a few
a few efforts we'll just move along move
along i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from brian who says if
reasons to vote for democrats was made
into a movie we would be living in that
world right now you are
righter than you know that you are
actually because for those who are new
to the program
reasons to vote for democrats a
comprehensive guide it was my number one
national best-selling blank book i came
out in 2017 and hit number one and trump
endorsed it and
it really
it really owned the lips you know they
really didn't like it and they they got
all upset and everything and threatened
me with accusations of plagiarism it's a
blank book
anyway i checked the sales numbers
yesterday i was just curious with a
democrat president democrat house
democrat senate democrat establishment
blowing everything right now i was
curious how the book was selling
the book is selling like hotcakes the
book is selling like it just came out
and
look it's a simple joke okay so i don't
think it's because of the quality of the
book i think it's because people are
seeing that the democrat party is
not only
wrong-minded in what it's doing but
absolutely incompetent as well
you know
when you want to get that blood flowing
when you want to get that good iron-rich
blood flowing start feeling good
start feeling strong and ready to go i
would strongly recommend you check out
good ranchers good ranchers is making
sure that you have got good extremely
high quality american meat on the table
did you know 80 of the grass-fed beef in
the united states sold in the united
states is not actually american even
sometimes it'll say american it'll use
kind of funny wording it's actually from
overseas that's why i get my meat from
goodranchers.com i ate it last night i
ate the burgers from good ranchers last
night they are magnificent they're
delicious their product is 100 american
and 100 delicious
when you buy your steak and chicken from
good ranchers not only are you getting
amazing meat you're also supporting
american farms head on over there right
now labor day is right around the corner
order the best meat today go to
goodranchers.com to buy now subscribe
today save 20 on each box of
mouth-watering meats subscribing brings
the cost down to less than five bucks a
meal five bucks a meal it's unbelievable
right now get an additional 20 bucks off
in free express shipping if you go to
goodranchers.com
use codenoles at checkout 20 bucks off
free express shipping at
goodranchers.com knowles know where your
meet comes from with goodranchers.com
there's a republican congressman who is
reportedly missing in afghanistan
because he's on a
action hero-like mission to individually
just personally rescue a family of four
or five
i this is a real story
he has attempted to get into afghanistan
two other times once through greece and
once i believe through tajikistan and
both times he was turned away and he
apparently got into a fight with the
embassy because they wouldn't let him
through he's just trying to go in with a
bunch of cash to get out of afghanistan
and
but now the reports are he did make it
in we don't really know how we don't
know if they're true or not obviously
there's a lot of lot more questions than
answers
but the reports are that he did make it
in we don't know how he's got a bunch of
money and he's just gonna buy and shoot
his way out of afghanistan and save this
family
this is awesome this is great
i get why the embassies turned him away
and said no you can't just go on a
one-man rogue mission into afghanistan
but
one i'm glad that we've got a little
do-it-yourselfer here who's actually
going to take matters into his own hands
and two
this shows you
the incompetence of the bureaucracy of
the blob the state department and
everyone else over there
even a u.s congressman can't get answers
even when a united states elected
congressman calls and says hey get this
family out he he can't get anywhere so
he's got to take matters into his own
hands
it shows you how little faith we have in
the the deep state the official
washington you know the or rather the
the permanent washington the elected
people come and go but the permanent
bureaucracy the permanent government
remains
and not even the elected guys can get
answers out of them
none of us can get answers
jensaki
giving a press conference was asked a
very simple question
we know that there are americans who
wanted to get out of afghanistan who are
currently trapped in afghanistan even
though you told us that we would not
leave any americans behind who wanted to
get out okay that's where we are right
now we don't know how many
are still in afghanistan so we just
here's a simple question did any of
those americans get out
today
on afghanistan
is there any sense of if and how many
americans might have left
today
is there even a way to track that from
the u.s government at this point well i
will say we remain in touch through a
range of means of communication email
text whatsapp that's something that we
could certainly do from here but also
having a presence in doha and diplomats
in the region will enable that to happen
locally or
close by as well i don't have an update
for you on the numbers um but that's
something the state department would
have the best assessment of so no do you
know of any americans who got out today
the answer is no but you don't want to
say no so she had to give this word
salad of well you know we i we've been
texting well good good i'm sure that's a
great relief to the americans who are
waiting for the taliban to come and
knock it i say no but i've got a text
from jen saki it's all going to be fine
right
so that has been the white house line
and the state department line and the
pentagon line from the beginning no
we're in touch with them we're not going
to abandon them or oh shoot we abandoned
them well we're not we don't worry it'll
be fine we'll get them out it's okay
they're not going to be stuck there if
they don't want to be
however you are seeing that line begin
to change the narrative is shifting
because
the biden administration did strand
certain americans so
now the line from the pentagon is not
we won't leave any americans
and it's not even okay we did but we're
gonna get him out
the line is
don't worry it's not a big deal we
strand americans behind enemy lines all
the time
so what does that look like how does
diplomacy get those people out of the
taliban controlled afghanistan
it's not completely unlike the way we do
it elsewhere around the world i mean we
have americans that get stranded in
countries all the time all the time it's
just not a big deal okay come on why are
you making such a big deal that now
you've got a civil war in afghanistan
between the taliban and isis
which is one of those
one of those wars where you're just sort
of hoping they both lose you know
neither of these are good
winners potentially but yeah we've got
americans stranded there but it's no big
deal it happens all the time it's just
like you know when a guy misses his
flight out of germany
it's just like that or out of italy you
know it's it happens all the time
i don't think this happens all the time
i think actually this is kind of a
special case
and you've heard this from people who
wanted to stay in afghanistan forever
they said look what we've been in
germany for years
right germany and afghanistan are
different and i think we all know that
and we all know that there are different
risk profiles and we all know that they
are are just different peoples and
different they have different sort of
statecraft and germany is an actual
nation and afghanistan is not and never
has been and it's a much more dangerous
situation in afghanistan and the way we
know that it is a big deal is because
you gave us many assurances that this
would not happen
and if this were just an ordinary thing
that happens all the time i don't i
don't think you would have made a point
to give all those assurances
so saki blew it kirby over at the
pentagon blew it the state department is
blowing it
so joe biden came out he gave another
speech to try his hand at this
the speech was supposed to happen i
forgot what time yesterday afternoon it
was delayed by a lot half an hour 45
minutes maybe up to an hour delayed
why
why first of all why is joe biden giving
important national addresses in the
afternoon
in my lifetime every important national
address certainly to declare the end of
a war oh my gosh would have been in
prime time it would have been in the
evening when more people are home from
work when more people are paying
attention
joe biden doesn't give evening addresses
almost ever why is that
why why won't he give an address past 6
p.m or 4 pm for that matter
why was it delayed
what was going on
what could he or could he not do
so joe biden
i don't know i don't know how he got his
energy but he got a little jolt of
energy spent the speech yelling at
everyone
and he came out forcefully with the
thesis
we didn't know if it was going to be
don't blame me it's not my fault i
didn't want to do this we didn't know if
this was going to be this is this is
great but i don't know it's not that's
not my fault or we didn't know if this
was going to be this is my decision
this is my decision i'm owning it i made
the choice i'm the decider so at the
beginning of the speech
joe biden chose the third option
this is my decision
i'm pulling out of afghanistan and i'm
sticking to it
in april
i made a decision to end this war
okay in april i made the decision to end
this war
i i think politically this was probably
a smart move he's getting killed for
afghanistan right now his numbers are
tanking in the polls
but sometimes a wrong decision is is
better than indecision and i'm not
saying the decision to pull out was
wrong
i think what americans want to see from
their commander-in-chief though no
matter how well or how terribly things
go is accountability they want to say
the buck stops here this this was my
decision i'm sticking to it which biden
did until he blamed everything on trump
now
look i'm not saying i've got the
greatest memory in the world
but it seems to me that things have
changed here okay now if you want to
preserve your great memories i would
strongly recommend you check out paint
your life i love having beautiful art on
my walls i think it's very important one
for my little baby to see beautiful
things as he grows up but it's important
for me too it really changes the way you
interact with your home you're not going
to find better art anywhere than paint
your life
paintyourlife.com i love these guys the
way it works you get a professional
hand-painted portrait created from any
of your photos
at an unbelievably affordable price you
can even combine photos of people you
say i want this guy from this photo this
one you work with the team of
world-class artists until every detail
is perfect you're proofing it the whole
time
and it's a real painting in my i like
the oil paintings but you can get other
kinds of paintings too it's real it's
not some trick it's not just some
computer thing it's a real beautiful
painting i have one of these hanging in
my living room i'm about to get another
one it's just magnificent delivery is
fast you can receive your portrait i'm
not joking in as little as two weeks i
got a beautiful portrait of my mother
i've gotten one for my step brother's
wedding at paintyourlife.com there's no
risk if you don't love the final
painting your money is refunded
guaranteed right now is a limited time
offer get 20 off your painting that's 20
off and free shipping to get this
special offer text michael to 64 000.
that's mich ael to 64 000. text michael
to 64 000 paint your life celebrate the
moments that matter most terms apply
available paint your life dot com slash
terms text michael to 64 000.
joe biden opens his national address on
the end of the war in afghanistan and he
says i made the decision to end this war
now
just as a fact check here he didn't
he
he is reiterating a decision that was
made 18 months ago by donald trump
donald trump signed the agreement to end
the war in afghanistan and joe biden's
very salty about that because he wants
credit for ending the war
because he knows that it's a popular
thing to end the war in afghanistan so
he says i made the decision even though
that's not true but then
just five minutes later in the speech
he blames trump for everything that went
wrong
my predecessor the former president
signed an agreement with the taliban
to remove u.s troops by may the first
just months after i was inaugurated by
the time i came to office
the taliban was in his strongest
military position
since 2001
controlling or contesting nearly half of
the country
the previous administration's agreement
said
that if we stuck to the may first
deadline that they had signed on to
leave by
the taliban wouldn't attack any american
forces
but if we stayed
all bets were off
so we're left with a simple decision
either follow through on the commitment
made by the last administration and
leave afghanistan
or say we weren't leaving and commit
another tens of thousands more troops
going back to war
so lame this is so lame dude
either take responsibility or don't i
think it's in your political interest to
say it's all you and the buck stops here
but
pick a lane
pick a lane you know what else is lame
is calling them the taliban taliban
taliban was funded by pakistan
you speak english taliban pakistan
so he says my predecessor made a deal
with the taliban right he made the deal
he ended the war so now you don't get
credit for ending the war no but i made
the decision to end the war well you
just said that trump made the decision
no i i made the good parts i did the i
want credit for the good parts but i
want him to get responsibility for the
bad parts
so okay what is he actually saying trump
did trump made a deal with the taliban
to end the war in afghanistan and he
said we'd be out by may so why weren't
you out by may
wouldn't that wouldn't that have if that
was the deal
wouldn't that have minimized all of this
risk all of this chaos all of this rush
all of this question of how
much you're overstaying the deadline
that you agreed to
get out by may so he couldn't get out by
may he bungled that
then he tries to get out by august and
it's a complete catastrophe
then he's even less coherent and
unfortunately this is the kind of
language we always hear with afghanistan
what it because it's a divisive issue do
you
do you want to stay there forever and
we're just going to yeah go in there
america glass the place we're going to
own it or do you want to get out do you
want to say who cares i don't care about
that backwater that god forsaken tribal
land get out of there bring our troops
home build
nation build back here in america what
is it what even the conservatives are
divided on this question and and joe
biden can't pick a side because joe
biden is not a conviction politician joe
biden is an empty suit he has been his
whole career so he licks his finger he
puts his finger up in the air he figures
out which way the wind is blowing and
then depending on that day or that hour
or that minute
that's the position he's going to hold
so so now he's trying to use the
rhetoric of get out of afghanistan we've
been there too long
to make a case for staying in
afghanistan
struck isis k remotely
days after they murdered 13 of our
service members
and dozens of innocent afghans
and to isis k
we are not done with you yet
as commander-in-chief
i firmly believe the best path to guard
our safety and our security lies in a
tough
unforgiving targeted precise strategy
that goes after terror where it is the
day
not where it was two decades ago
that's what's in our national interest
okay so he's talking tough we're not
done with you yet i mean we are we're
leaving we're gone but where are
does anybody believe that no
then he says
pay attention to the words here
isis k
we're gonna fight terror where it is
today
not where it was two decades ago what is
isis k isis k is the offshoot of the
islamic state specifically in kurusan
what is kurusan it's afghanistan
and parts of iran too it's afghanistan
hey
afghan terror group we're not going to
fight terror where it was two decades
ago which was in afghanistan we're going
to fight terror where it is today in
afghanistan except we're leaving
afghanistan
yeah that'll show him
that'll show him just completely
incoherent this man has soup for brains
and it's not because he's senile he is
senile he's obviously in decline he
obviously can't stay up past six o'clock
which is why he gives the afternoon
speeches and he clearly can't do those
very well either because he shows up
late to them they're trying to get his
energy up
he he can't read the teleprompter the
speech was more slurred than even they
usually are which is a bad thing it's a
bad thing when the leader of your
country is like this reminds me of
chernenko one of these premiers at the
end of the soviet union who lived for
about
six weeks you know he barely he could
barely do anything it's pathetic it's
pathetic and it's not good for the
country not good for him by not good for
the country but when i say he's super
brains i'm not saying it's because he's
in decline he's always been super brains
he's never
been all that smart
he used to lie about his academic record
because of this because he would
graduate at the bottom of his classes
he's just a glad hander he's just a
backslapper he's just a simper smiler
you know hey i'll go fix your pothole
kind of politician
and he is not up to the challenge that
we face right now which is why our
foreign policy is confused which is why
he doesn't know was the decision to
leave trump's fault or his fault or
trump's accomplishment or his
accomplishment
is it good or is it bad is it a great
success or is it a terrible failure are
we going to leave afghanistan are we
going to stay there we're going to fight
terror we're not going to fight terror
what is it they don't know he doesn't
want to take a position
now
there of course there's going to be
terrorism in afghanistan there's going
to be terrorism in pakistan pakistan
there's going to be terrorism in yemen
there's going to be terrorism in africa
there's going to be terrorism
and a lot of different places okay and
we are going to have to be smart about
how you fight it when you fight at what
you do
there is terror at home okay do you
remember last year
when blm and antifa
terrorists burned the country down city
to city to city
targeting civilians to achieve political
ends right the most basic definition of
terrorism when they did that
and they did that with the encouragement
and sometimes financial support of
elected democrats one of whom is now the
vice president of the united states
remember that so these antifa guys these
blm guys they're not just running in the
streets throwing molotov cocktails into
people's store windows
they're also in the classroom james
o'keefe over project veritas
has an undercover interview with a
member of antifa
who is a teacher at a school in
sacramento
who who doesn't even hide it it turns
out he actually flies an antifa flag in
the classroom i have 180 days to turn
him into revolutionaries how do you do
that how do you schedule
sacramento organization that is under
the banner of antipas is very loosely
organized right um so like yeah when
when there is like right wing rallies
and stuff then we like
we'll create an opposition to that yeah
beautiful where would he go to
connect with some of these organizations
like
i post calendar every week and then so
like it's and i do it for extra credit
so they get points for doing it like so
that's encourages them to do it and i've
i've had like students show like
protests community events you know
tabling food distribution all sorts of
sorts of things they when they go they
take pictures they write up a reflection
that's their extra credit like i i have
an antifa flag on my on my wall um and a
student complained about that and you
said it made them feel uncomfortable
well this is meant to make fascists feel
uncomfortable so if you feel
uncomfortable i i don't really know what
to do like
maybe you shouldn't be aligning with the
values that this is antithetical too
yeah maybe maybe you shouldn't support
america for instance right you shouldn't
salute the american flag you shouldn't
support the american president when it
was donald trump
you shouldn't you shouldn't do that if
you do that
well i guess you're just not going to
align with our class right
yesterday i mentioned
the teacher who has her students say the
pledge of allegiance to the pride flag
the pride progress flag that's the new
one with even more colors and it's like
sex and race and whatever we'll get to
her in a second there's an update on her
she is like uncle sam
compared to this guy she's like george
patton for goodness sakes compared to
this guy i said with her that she should
be fired but she shouldn't be thrown in
jail she shouldn't be ostracized this
guy
i don't know i think we should get a
little tougher with this guy
i don't think i like william f buckley
jr founder of the post-war conservative
movement i don't think this guy has any
right to stay out of prison i don't i
certainly he should be fired he should
not be teaching but i if you're a member
of antifa i don't think you really have
a right to stay out of prison i don't
think you really have many rights at all
if you're a member of a terrorist
organization that openly seeks to
overturn our system of government and
that has actively engaged in acts of
terror and regularly does that i don't
think you have very many rights at all
today you do i mean today you're you're
much more protected than the average
trump supporter
in the public square in the sort of
activism you can engage in but i don't
think that should be the case and i
think conservatives need to get a little
bit tougher in the way that we write the
law and enforce the law and the way we
engage in politics you know i'm
extremely excited to tell you that our
backstage in october is going to be
staged a little bit differently
you know that last backstage man that
one got pretty heated we were told it
was me and drew and matt and ben and
jeremy were all just kind of
fighting about afghanistan it was really
intense i really enjoyed it and i felt
everyone made good arguments
some people made better arguments and
others i would say but but it was really
good i really enjoyed it
so we want to up the ante a little bit
more we want to turn the intensity up a
little bit more instead of just tuning
in from your home you'll be able to see
us live and on stage right at the ryman
auditorium here in nashville join me
jeremy ben matt drew candice owens for
backstage
like never before we have a very special
offer for our members if you're a daily
wire member you have a special 12-hour
window
to buy your tickets ahead of general
admission starting tomorrow thursday
september 2nd at 10 a.m central it's
only 12 hours but well that's a decent
amount of time so go in there check your
email you get a special code that you
can use to pre-order your tickets if you
are not a member then you're just going
to have to wait until tickets go on sale
this friday september 3rd unless what
happens if you become a member now
though i should i don't know i actually
don't know the answer to that so maybe
you do that just to be safe mark your
calendar make sure you don't miss out
we'll be right back with a lot more
i mentioned yesterday a teacher who
posted a tick tock video
and the the video was joking about how
she does not have an american flag in
her classroom
and so her students are supposed to
stand up and say the pledge of
allegiance but she says you don't need
to stand you don't need to utter the
pledge even if you do stand and then
some of the students said well you know
if we want to we don't have a flag so
we're not
what are we pledging allegiance to and
she said oh we have a flag and she
pointed to the rainbow
the pride progress flag which isn't even
just a gay thing it's like a gay race
it's just like all of these it's just a
flag for leftism for a kind of imperial
leftism that's beyond national borders
that's that is supposed to replace the
american flag
so yesterday on the show
i said that that teacher should be fired
i don't think there's first of all i
don't think there's any guarantee of
academic freedom in the third grade
classroom or whatever i don't i think
our understanding of academic freedom
has has been perverted by the left
everywhere this also speaking of william
f buckley jr was the point of his book
god and man that yell superstitions of
academic freedom that
launched the post-war conservative
movement and by the way just speaking of
that book there is a new edition the
70th anniversary edition of that book
coming out and i'm very honored to
report that i got to write the
introduction to this new new edition of
the book it's the book that started it
all the post-war conservative movement
and so i'm pleased to be able to offer
an introduction and
unfortunately we've forgotten a lot of
what buckley said in that book this
teacher does not have any right to do
this
okay
so the good news is
she's being investigated
there's an official investigation from
the newport mesa unified school district
in orange county
teacher's name is kristen pitzen
and she might lose her job as she should
she should i don't i don't think that
this woman should be thrown in prison i
don't think she should be completely
ostracized from society i think she
should be allowed to go get another job
somewhere else but just not a teaching
job because she's a bad teacher
her teaching is contrary to the best
interests of a student if the student
wants to be educated and the teaching is
distinctly anti-american one of the
purposes of education especially public
education is to make citizens
that's what that's what it's there for
is to make good citizens and what she is
doing is making bad citizens she's
discouraging students from being good
citizens and she's filling their heads
with a lot of claptrap that is wrong and
bad for them so she should not ever be
permitted to teach a student again
she should be allowed to go get a job in
retail she should be allowed to go get a
job at a marketing company she'd be
allowed to go get a job wherever she
wants really but just
not as a teacher she failed at that and
there need to be consequences for that
sort of thing and we the people have the
right
to have a say in how the next generation
of americans is educated
speaking of kooky teachers
the la teachers union has more demands
you know during covid
the la teacher union they they
misinterpreted the covid lockdowns as a
semi-permanent vacation
for teachers who are already overpaid
and overprotected in one of the worst
school districts in
the united states
so
the la teacher union
is now back
they're not just demanding whatever
changed hours and plexiglas and open
windows and certain school sizes and
classroom changes they're not just
demanding that
they're demanding a mandatory vaccine
for all students
this is not about the students
because young people
have a very very very very very very low
risk of facing serious complications of
the coronavirus
this is about the teachers protecting
themselves
even though the teachers face you
generally speaking a very very very very
low risk of serious complications from
the coronavirus
they
are going to force students to take an
experimental drug that the students
really don't need
to protect
them
themselves
it seems kind of backwards doesn't it
you know you know what's crazier
the judge who just stripped a mother of
her parental rights
because she refused to get the
experimental drug to protect against the
cough that doesn't pose much of a threat
to her kid
you got you got two people the mother
who's saying stop screwing with our kids
lives to the school board you demons
and the judge who just took a child an
11 year old child
away from his mother
because she wouldn't get the jab
that happened
rebecca furlet just appeared in court on
zoom she's the mother
it was a child support hearing with her
ex-husband they've got an
eleven-year-old son
and cook county judge james shapiro
suddenly asked during the hearing out of
the blue this had not the hearing had
nothing to do with kovid he said have
you gotten
the experimental drug
and the mother said no because she had
had bad reactions to other vaccines so
she had a pretty good reason and
we know that there have been
deaths from this vaccine
women have died from blood clots because
of this vaccine
one of the coveted vaccines and we know
that other people have suffered
myocarditis periocarditis nerve damage
and then the judge
stripped this woman of her parenting
time
until she gets the experimental drug
two weeks this kid was prevented from
seeing his mother
this 11 year old son prevented from his
mother for two weeks
finally because there was a public
outcry this degenerate idiot judge
reversed his decision
only because of media backlash what do
you think is worse for the kid to
be exposed to germs that really don't
pose much of a threat to him
actually forget that for a second
people who are vaccinated are spreading
the virus so i don't even know that it
would reduce the amount of germs that he
would be exposed to
so what's better for the kid have the
mother do the special religious ritual
where you get the jab even though it's
not going to do very much for her son if
anything at all
or
take take the kid away
from the mother
what what do you think or rather i'm
sorry let the kid be with his mother
what do you think take the kid away from
his mother until she gets the jab or let
the kid stay with his mother where he
really doesn't face any increased risk
from the virus that doesn't pose much of
a threat to him at all
lunacy i'm glad this judge reversed his
decision but this guy
should be run out of town on the rail no
question about it i'm going to talk to
ben maybe it's ben's cousin say ben
what's going on with this judge shapiro
get him out of there insane
the people who are pushing this hysteria
this neurosis
don't believe it they don't believe it
they don't think you need to wear a mask
they don't think you need to social
distance they don't think you need to
stay home they're lying to you
and if you and i know neurotic people i
have a lot of neurotic people in my
friend group and in my family who have
who have bought into this madness
i know why it's attractive i know why if
the whole culture is telling you to do
something you feel compelled to do it
but i'm just telling you these people
don't believe it
elizabeth warren
lyowatha
just showed up to
a
wedding in new mexico
the wedding was for the secretary of the
interior deb holland and her boyfriend
skip sare they just they just got
married okay very nice good
congratulations good for them they show
up to this wedding
and very few people are wearing masks
elizabeth warren not wearing a mask
dancing with people having a nice time
new mexico
has a mask mandate
new mexico has a democratic governor
michelle lujan grisham she has a mask
mandate and elizabeth warren the u.s
senator violated that mask mandate
because none of these people think it
matters none of these people actually
think the masks are important at all
elizabeth warren probably agrees with me
on masks in fact i know she does because
of the way she behaves regardless of
what she says she agrees with me that
the masks just don't really matter at
all
but
she's gonna convince you that they
really do matter and
and
neurotic people and power-hungry
psychopaths are going to act on that and
judges are going to take kids away from
their mothers
and
teachers are going to keep kids out of
school
and we're the crazy ones and that nurse
who says this is crazy there she's the
crazy one right
i don't think so
the the rot
that we are seeing here
in our government
is coming not just from the vaccine not
just from afghanistan not just from what
pick whatever problem is going on in the
country
it's coming from
the belief of our ruling class that they
don't owe you anything
they don't owe you answers they don't
owe you good government they don't owe
you
the fulfillment of their promises they
don't owe you you're nothing but a
nuisance to them
they have the right to rule
you can't say boo about it
and they're not even going to dignify
your
befuddlement at this with a response
this this is clearest among joe biden
who talks about afghanistan and then the
minute anyone asks a question he just
turns around and walks away
and occasionally he'll say look i'll
answer a question about the hurricane
and a reporter says what about the
americans you're straining in afghani he
says i'm not talking about afghanistan
see ya bye sorry haha what are you going
to do about it so
this is not just joe biden spreading out
throughout the administration anthony
blinken
complete incompetent secretary of state
anthony blinken
gives an update yesterday about why
everything's gone to absolute pot in
afghanistan and then he gets to the end
of his speech people have a lot of
questions obviously for him there are
events happening in real time that we
need answers to
he just turns his back and walks on out
we'll honor all those great men and
women from the united states and many
other countries
who risked or sacrificed their lives
as part of this long mission
right up to today
thanks for listening
secretary this administration break its
word that no american would be left
behind
thanks for listening that's the most
interesting thing he said in his entire
i'm not even going to play most of his
update and his address it's it's one
doesn't tell you very much and two it's
meaningless because these people have
either lied or just through their own
incompetence gotten things wrong so
there's no there's no value in listening
to what they have to say because we
can't rely on it we can't trust it
but the most interesting thing he said
there is thanks for listening
he turns on his heels and walks out
not thank you for coming not i'm glad
you're here let's take some questions
thanks for listening
thanks for here i said what i have to
say
now see you later
bye bye
and
he's not taking questions because he
doesn't have to they don't need to
answer you they're going to paper over
everything exhibit a my friends from the
washington post
a column by jennifer rubin until very
recently jennifer rubin is a liberal
columnist and she appears on liberal
networks and she writes for a liberal
paper and she has liberal opinions but
until very recently she pretended to be
a conservative columnist i'm not joking
she had it in her twitter bio
she was introduced as conservative
columnist jennifer rubin conservative
commentator jennifer rubin and but she's
not she's not conservative at all and
she almost exclusively supports
democrats and she never has anything
nice to say about conservatives or
republicans and all of her views are
liberal views
but the blob and at least until very
recently
would pretend that she was a
conservative they do this a lot they
have
what i call court jester conservatives
you might call them controlled
opposition
you know they're just they're just jokes
court eunuchs the sort of people who
their whole job is to pretend to
represent an alternative viewpoint but
actually really all they do is prop up
the liberal establishment and so
jennifer rubin was that until it just
became so ridiculous that they had to
acknowledge she's no longer conservative
so headline here
the state department deserves more
credit
for its effort to evacuate americans
from afghanistan
deserves more credit and the state
department was tweeting this out the
administration was tweeting this out
state had to imagine a universe of as
many as 15 000 americans
that were you know stuck in afghanistan
the state department's been criticized
for not beginning mass evacuations of
afghans months ago as far back as april
uh it began sending one notice after
another they were doing oh they were so
good you know texting and yeah you know
sure it looks bad on tv but actually
they're doing they're doing a great job
and they deserve more credit
everyone's everyone's tweeting this out
this is going to be the official story
it's already happening what a success
this was any problems with it were
trump's fault but what a success this
was
and you're going to be told not to
believe your lying eyes
you're going to be told it's great
it's all going well
and you're going to be told the only
downside is we didn't take more afghans
we should have taken more we should have
opened our doors and our borders more
but even that has been run perfectly
sure we on the last planes out of
afghanistan we didn't get a single
american on there and sure we just
packed full of afghans but listen they
were totally vetted except for the ones
that weren't vetted
here's a story convicted rapist
refugee from afghanistan was just caught
over here so
americans were having trouble getting
flights out of out of kabul so goddard
hidari
made it onto an ethiopian airlines
charter flight for evacuees this guy's
47 years old he made it to washington
d.c
finally at washington dulles airport
they found out that this refugee had
already been in america he
was moved to america in
the 20th century he was granted a green
card in the year 2000 and he apparently
pleaded guilty to rape
in 2010 in idaho and he was deported
he's a rapist convicted rapist and he
was deported to afghanistan and he made
it back into america but don't worry
we're vetting everyone it's so important
to get all these afghans out forget the
americans were there we have to get all
these afghans out
including the rapists
glad they caught him how many did they
not catch
how many made it through in the tens of
thousands upwards of a hundred thousand
afghans that got out
this is not just happening at one guy in
washington seven afghan refugees quote
unquote were just detained in germany
you know i guess they are refugees it
just turns out they're also criminals
and they shouldn't be allowed into these
countries they were detained in germany
uh one of them in cust is in custody
right now two are still
with the police at the airport three had
forged documents four had already been
deported from germany to afghanistan as
criminals and according to reports these
were serious crimes
serious crimes
we got to take all of them in
how many are not being caught how many
are slipping through a lot of these
people don't have any documents
whatsoever
great job they're not getting enough the
state department which handles this
stuff
not getting enough credit they're not
getting enough credit
and it'll just move right along
and you we'll raise a little bit of a
fuss about it here you'll hear about it
on maybe a few conservative
channels although frankly most of the
conservative outlets are there their
only problem is that we didn't take more
afghans the only problem is we didn't
stay longer in afghanistan right
but you'll hear about it here you'll
hear about what happened
and then they'll just move on and then
we'll start funding the talib but we're
going to be allies of the taliban we're
probably going to conduct joint missions
against isis we'll probably be back in
afghanistan pretty soon because the blob
don't care what you want to do that's
government of we the people is uh
transformed it's transformed and you
don't get to ask any questions about it
i'm michael nolan's the michael knowles
shall see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bora our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva michael
knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show